tokyo game show and III are great but
for many anime and manga fans the
highlight of the year is jump festa if
you like mex pirates and tales than van
die namco's announcements that the event
should make you pretty happy first up
jojo's bizarre adventure eyes of heaven
it's a 3d brawler coming to the
PlayStation 4 in 2016 and yes you'll be
able to get it here in the States tells
obverse area is the 16th game in the
tale series and it's coming to ps4 and
steam that we don't know when just yet
for fans of space battles there's Mobile
Suit Gundam extreme vs force it's a PS
Vita exclusive set for 2016 lastly
there's one piece burning blood we
already knew it was coming to consoles
but now the latest pirate brawler has
been confirmed for a steam release next
year pre-order bonuses were announced
but the highlight is burning bloods
marineford edition which includes two
figures of white beard in his grave plus
an art book only 5,000 units are being
produced so you'll need that quickly to
get your hands on this treasure when it
comes to manga especially shonen jump
there's plenty of news to go around to
stay caught up keep your eye on gamespot
we like Gundam to
you